[Music]  [Music]  where did the signature feather on the  guitar come from my sister got it for me  as a present and it's just something I  didn't know what to do with so I put it  on my guitar and that just kind of the  mystical side of it always stuck with me  is it time Kate for a rocker to win  American Idol you know I really do think  it is it's because I mean I feel like  there's been some rockers in the past  but I represent a specific you know a  time period that was amazing like you  know Led Zeppelin and Hendrix and all  that and I want to you know modernize it  a little bit and bring to the stage like  what it is that I feel like America  needs so vote for me  [Music]